[Music]
hi hi everybody
oh it's finally here
I mean it's anyone playing drums around
here because you know I kind of fearing
beatings or I think it's my heart
beating so loud and fast I mean I'm so
nervous but yeah
anyway thank you Rachel for your kind
words about me first of all I'd like to
thank just confuse this wonderful
opportunity this is my second time in
jazz confit you and also my second time
in Berlin I really had a nice time back
then and also hoping to have same this
year too I was here last year on
scholarship again whose thanks to Jason
feel they are doing an amazing job
providing scholarship to diverse culture
people and people from yeah who wouldn't
have been here if there was no is called
so around the floors maybe for just
country you team and yeah few
disclaimers and excuses this is going to
be my first table talk at International
Conference and also my first ever talk
in English language I used I'm used to
giving in the Pali language but this is
going to be my first ever talk thank you
so you might hear some broken broken
English says and yeah she brings up the
words so bear with me so and another
disclaimer the challenges and overcoming
techniques that I'm going to mention
here in this talk are based on my total
I mean based on my personal experience
and its subjected to change according to
the country according to the organizer
so yeah before starting my sister today
I would like to have a few quizzes with
the guys and you can raise your hand if
you are if you agree with it and you
don't have to do anything if you don't
you know have you ever started or take
community before anyone I can see few
hats so anyone here currently leading a
community you don't have to start you
and you don't have to be the founder but
you are currently leading the community
anybody you feel so and all the last
questions how many of you believe in
community I believe I mean how many
think a community can help you grow it
can help you be more productive and even
help you can be a better person
nice that's what I feel too in fact what
I am today where I am today is all
because of the community I'm so into it
sorry about me I'm roastin Gautam by the
way good afternoon everybody
I've come all the way from Nepal just
finished my bachelor's degree in
computer science actually waiting for
the result of my end semester so fingers
crossed I'm currently working as a
full-time coder in my own company called
it's called brain and technology then
you can see the spelling right there I
spend most of my times developing mobile
apps using react native having doing
mobile apps development for foyers now
just after joining the campus when I was
in school maybe grade 8 or 9 my dad
brought a computer and I was so into it
I mean at that time I used to play a lot
of football I mean you understand for
food all right so maybe soccer for
somebody so I used to play a lot of food
but after that I got the computer in my
home and you know in school
they used to teach us qbasic and one of
my elder brother introduced me with this
tool called Mitchell basic and I just
got into programming world from grade 9
and I was I used to get so fascinated by
community back then as well I mean I
used to create and join the Facebook
groups for programming like I created
one called
programmers Wells or something like that
yeah there was Facebook I'm not that old
also I used to train different chat
rooms in yahoo messenger
I love so yeah about talking about the
communities these are a few of the
communities that I'm currently involved
in and also I was involved in kicking
MGS KTM stands for Kathmandu it's a
capital of Nepal maybe you know that
and it's KPMG a small JavaScript
community actually a meetup group in
Kathmandu currently leading I'm
currently leading this community so I'll
talk about this in more detail in a
moment
next stop is where we can come and it's
a wave conference in there pal
I'm so excited to talk about this and
I'm one of the proud organizers have you
ever heard of a week in Kathmandu
anybody so you will hear about it today
I also talk about this in more detail in
a movement right so I know there is
Mozilla Nepal it's a community of
holiday volunteers who want to
contribute in open-source and also in
the open way if we want to contribute
who loves open-source tool or want to
contribute in Mozilla project we have a
volunteer organized various events and
activities like
localization of the browsers privacy
campaigns and workshops related to open
wave I'm actually a mozilla rep as well
for Nepal another docker campus
ambassador programme my volunteer is a
local chemist remember sorry
docker campus ambassador in my campus
while I was there
so let's talk about Kitty MJS Kitty is I
said earlier earlier KDM yes is a
community of just developers in
Kathmandu where we gather together share
of things around JavaScript just we talk
and it was started two years ago as a
Facebook group it's all still there I
mean yeah so we are currently six people
managing the community six core
contributors until now we have managed
to organize around 13 events and in our
Facebook group there are around 1,500
members so I'm not onto this meme
numbers and all but I want you to have
it in the slide so that I could talk
about it okay so the last meet of that
we did was on May 25 yeah this May 25 we
do regular meetups of different formats
like sometimes formal sometimes informal
and sometimes mix of both yeah this is
the photo from the last bit of KTM
Cheers
whattup 13 there were around 65 people I
guess with the four speakers it's it was
about testing and security in JavaScript
so let me talk about where we can
confront the conference that I'm so
excited about I'm so proud about where
you can catch mondo is probably only web
conference in Nepal I mean there are a
few conferences that are related to just
WordPress or something like that but
it's a only conference that's related to
the pure wave so it's a two-day
conference but a bit different different
then just comes to you in the first day
it's all talks and citizens is like this
but on the second day we do outdoor
activities like you know trekking and
hiking and roaming around the city
together right I want to talk about the
motivation behind this conference so
there are a lot of experienced
developers promising startups in Nepal
tech communities in Nepal who are
scattered and are going unnoticed the
sort of main motivation behind this
conference is making these people come
together and share about their stuffs
with each other and yeah get together
and build something right and also it's
very economically hard for me please
like in their salary ways to come to
this place and attend the conference and
everybody is not as lucky as me to get a
scholarship or you know to get my talk
accepted and come here to attend the
conference so so yeah certainly where
you can have fun dreams to provide these
kind of opportunities to attend and meet
people to attend high-class talks for
the local people in Nepal so let me talk
about a little bit of behind the scenes
how it all started and all so I was
attending this conference in Iceland
it's Jays convice land you may have
heard of I was talking to one of these
speakers of GSK Iceland he actually
asked me if there were any conferences
that happening in Nepal but at that
point of time I was speechless actually
so I was really sad I came back to Nepal
and in one of the local meet off in my
surprise I found this group of people
who were actually planning to do a
conference in a ball so I was so excited
you know I mean I was attending these
conferences in all the places of the
world but I had not any conferences in
my places so I was so excited I when the
team successfully organized wave we
can't cap onto the for the first time in
2018 so you want to know the best
but the speaker who asked me about the
conference in Nepal will be speaking and
where we can confirm to 2019 in
September 22 22 how cool is that so
these are some of the steps from 2018
edition of WWE TM it's where we can
Kathmandu we were initially we're
actually expecting only 80 people's I
guess 80 around 80 people's to come and
five or six speakers but you are
surprised yeah as you can see in the
stats there were 300 plus attendees and
10 speakers from 14 plus countries and
this is the group footer for where you
can find it 2018 so this was the
introduction of me and community it was
very long I know
so there are a lot of products perks I'm
growing together with community there
are a lot of perks of when leaving a
meetup group or organizing events and
conferences it's possible to grow
together with community right you guys
believed it before so if you haven't
hello what's final episode of Game of
Thrones at the upcoming slide might be
the spoiler for you but I hope it won't
matter anyway
yeah how many of you did you get is so
how do you think I came all this way I
mean if it wasn't for a community I
wouldn't have been able to here speaking
before you guys organizing meters and
conferences give me courage to do
challenging things that even even if I'm
not very good at it I don't have been
here talking I mean I don't have been
known about this conference or even
wouldn't have applied for the talk if it
wasn't for community and if I wasn't
involved in this kind of activities so
you will be more privileged so I was
listening to this podcast
called how I built this have anyone
heard of that how I built this yeah so I
was listening to this podcast by John
parity maybe I didn't get the
pronunciation right by John John John
apparently from BuzzFeed he was saying
like when you get initial success as he
did in the nothing for Huffington Post
sorry you'll get access to greater ideas
resources and people just that extract
me right in by this I mean when you lead
a community are organized this kind of
events even if you participate actively
in these programs you will have access
to more resources seniors in your fail
and many more valuable stops right so in
order to get these perks
I'm a find myself doing these things you
can have your own set of stuffs attend
the talks actively yes you are the
organizer of the meetup you might not
have a lot of time attending the parts
but you kept - I mean you can't try to
manage things in a such a way that you
are also attending the talks actively
which will surely help you grow your
professional lives and grow get some
skills how many of you agree on this yes
reaching out to these speakers reaching
out to these speakers will help you grow
your communication skills of course your
network of friends and professionals
will be widened enough to get more
opportunities at all challenges that I
faced so you are of course you are going
to face a lot of challenging challenges
if you are trying to conduct meetups in
small communities like Nepal right there
might be a lot of them in all different
in a different forms I will talk about
these challenges that I faced and I'm
facing in my place des pal and you can
always live to relate them to yours
no no wonder you might have different
sets of challenges
venues yeah in a small community like
Nepal it's really hard to get nice
conference hall for free of cost I mean
is we are not well funded so and that
could accumulate 50 more than 50
participants so I actually we I had to
postpone one of the meetups because
because of not getting the venue in time
right this was that was a very sad
moment
another challenge would be to find
sponsors you might not miss new sponsors
to run the meter but in fact most of the
meetups that I have organized tilted
sponsor free on the other hand it's a
real actually hard to organize meetups
without the sponsors I mean usually we
have hold assassins in this kind of
beetle but with no sponsors there are
not going to be foods and drinks for the
attendees right how actively one can
participate in the event a hungry
stomach right and also it's really nice
to give some token of loves to speakers
right so there are I first in in my
context I feel the main issue with
finding sponsor was like not so many
companies to approach for sponsorship
there were not enough companies there
are not enough big company companies in
the PAL sorry where I can approach for
sponsorship finding speakers turned out
to be a very hard stuff for me as well
in case of Nepal in case of me some of
the speakers don't really want to talk
in the small meetup like ours and most
of them most of the engineers hesitate
to talk in public I mean that's a real
problem in our place so if you want to
share something
community are if you have done some of
it amazing stuff that will help the
public please go forward
do not hesitate and give talk about in
the meetups it could be local or it
could be the conference like this right
it would really help the organizers seem
like the speakers attendees are also
like I first had challenges in attendees
as well senior engineers and developers
are not willing to attend the Meetup
maybe because they feel like they aren't
going to learn anything from the meter
but yeah most of the participants in the
meetups in Nepal are students also this
is the main thing I guess motivations in
team since we are non funded no we are
not funded by any big organizations
there might be the lose of motivations
in the team yeah too much or too less
meetups
this is a very big problem yeah because
of the lack of motivations and different
jobs of the people of the organizing
team there might be very less meetups
and also there might be too much of
littles so how to overcome these
challenges again these are based on my
experience and this these things are
subjected to change according to the
country according to the place and
according to the you know organize your
teams so you can try to find alternative
venues you know you can talk to these
schools and colleges and universities to
provide their premises as a venue you
can also conduct small meetups in coffee
shops and cafes where participants can
buy their own coffee and food and also
you can ask the venue providers to
provide light snacks and tea and coffee
for the attendees try different from us
of the meat of in my context I was
having this problem
senior developers and engineers wouldn't
like to come why they wouldn't like to
come in the meter is like they are not
going to learn anything from the these
talks they just want to build their
network but students they like to attend
the talks from the seniors and they like
to learn programming languages or
something like that so you can try to
have you know different formats of the
events like the dist orcs and should not
I mean does not have to be formal
meetups where two three guys comes and
say about some tools or frameworks right
so you can try doing informal meetups
where developers and meet-and-greet talk
about the live talk talk about their
side projects yeah you can also try
doing events in different time like
sometimes in morning sometimes in
afternoon and even in the winning right
so yeah online meetups in the Facebook
gap can be also very fruitful avoid to
frequent meetups this was the problem
that we actually first in the initial we
used to do meetups every week I mean
that was crazy
attendees and even yourself don't want
to lose all your weekends you know
giving going to the meetups and
listening to some stuff
having said that skipping six or seven
months for a meet-up is not healthy
either I mean you have to do regularly
it could be once in a month or twice you
know like I don't know once in two
months and something like that
another thing you can watch you can do
is let your team member lead the Meetup
I actually this did this recently that I
was just talking about May 25 meter
I was actually preparing for Jess
country you talks and all and I I didn't
have
enough time to conduct a meet-up so I
asked one of my team members to organize
this and do anything they like you know
and it was very good thing I mean there
was a lot of motivation all the all the
five people from the team came up and
started working on them and it was
successful I mean 65 people were there
and I heard it went a lot better also
you can't get engaged in social media
create Facebook groups and invite the
attendees to attend I mean to join the
group and ask questions or something
like that and yeah very very important
not yeah take feedbacks from your
attendees it's very important like I
told you earlier that we are trying to
have different formats of events right
right so it was because of the feedbacks
from the attendees so takeaways actively
participate to grow with the community
together involving community will
involvement in community will help you
grow your communication skills and
professional skills have self-motivated
members in your team avoid too much be
tops and too irregular meetups always
check feedbacks from that in this and
screw it just do it I mean if you
haven't started it just start it if you
are not getting involved intercom local
meetups just get involved it and thank
you this is Ross and Gautham you can
find me in the tutor and guitar thank
you actually one more thing if you want
to speak at where we can Kathmandu we
have just opened up our wildest wild
card speaker proposal call for proposals
for very limited time so make sure you
apply as soon as possible
thanks again
[Music]